all right guys
bang bang i've got will and willie here
with me there's a lot of w's in both of
your names
uh i'm super excited about this i feel
like uh willie is the og of on-chain
metrics
and will is uh fast becoming one of the
crucial pieces
of information in the market online
chain metrics as well
willie thanks so much for uh for joining
us today
yeah thanks having me pump absolutely
let's just start
with uh maybe you can introduce yourself
um and give us a little bit of
background in terms of why you got
interested into
on-chain metrics and kind of uh maybe
what you look at on a day-to-day basis
when you wake up
uh as a signal for what you think is
kind of the most important metrics
yeah okay i got into bitcoin in 2013 um
kind of coming from a
tech background you know startups always
into tech and data and that's what
appealed to me in
in bitcoin more the tech side of things
and um
as i sort of delved past um all the tech
um you know with this blockchain and i
started uh looking
um into what was you know data in there
trying to draw
conclusions from it and that ended up
becoming a field in its own right you
know i started an on-chain analysis
in 2016 um kind of put out some of the
first
on-chain indicators like nvt
sort of 2016 early 2017 that's how new
this whole field is and now
something like four five six um
companies dedicated providing this kind
of data to investors now
um so uh when we're looking on chain
it's really a look into the fundamentals
as the fundamentals of what
um investors are doing with the capital
you can see them
um come in you can see their movements
you can see the age of coins you can see
you know new people coming in to buy or
new people selling and you can draw
kind of conclusions um like if you see a
whole lot of new people
um selling and into a dip and
a bull season you you kind of know that
those are the
like the weekends being shaken out you
know if you see a whole lot of old hand
selling all of a sudden
that's a little bit more serious because
they're more experienced so
that kind of gives you an idea of what
we're looking at an on chain it's
looking at these
fundamental movements in capital from
real people less
the technical analysis which most
traders use which is essentially just
tracking um the price and volume
movements on exchanges and trying to
draw
um all sort of you know metrics around
that
ultimately um the fundamentals prevail
over the long term
um short term the technical analysis is
more
might say um timely it can
you can tie markets in a shorter time
frame but um
i've seen many many times in the bitcoin
market where the fundamentals say one
thing and the technicals say another
and um it's i've never seen the
fundamentals fail actually
so um you know when i wake up and i
check the markets i usually
check flows going in and out of the
exchanges give me an idea of the buying
power or the selling power of
real investors rather than just the
traders i also look at
you know one of these metrics that glass
node do is um
what they call liquid supply and that's
really a qualitative view
of the market where the coins are moving
between strong holders or weak holders i
use that
a lot just give me idea of you know
who's buying or selling and those two
combined give me a very good readout and
then
there's about i don't know 20 other
indicators i might look at depending on
the time on the
structure of the market glass node have
about three to four hundred charts um
so ultimately usually i all of them get
used um through
out a macro cycle it's just different
times like
obviously right now with china um
banning their miners you know looking at
the hash rate on the network
the the speed of the blocks processing
the miners wallets that sort of comes
into play
um so it's just kind of you know it's an
ecg i think it's like a
readout of this entire animal called
bitcoin and you can look at it in
200 different dimensions and on chain
analysis gives you that
willie i want to follow up with this
thread you put out maybe you could just
kind of break this down for listeners
the one you put out yesterday you're
looking at uh the the supply shock ratio
liquid supply ratio and then also
exchange flows
um you know i guess we could just kind
of get into real quick
what what exactly are those uh you know
metrics showing
and just kind of getting into this whole
uh you know like re reaccumulation phase
that
that we've been kind of describing yeah
okay so i i measure
supply shock in um two ways a
quantitative view
and a qualitative view um the
quantitative view
is really just um the speculative
inventory that's sitting on um
exchanges you know so you can draw a
pretty easy conclusion that
um the supplier sitting on exchanges are
the coins that are able to be
bought admittedly some of them are
long-term holders particularly on
coinbase where noobs sort of
and particularly retail store long-term
their coins but
mostly the coins on exchanges are
speculative coins
and um what you can see is um
as coins deplete off that inventory
there's
an effective supply shock so um you know
that's been
the story of this last 12 months
ever since covert hit the economy
we've been in the supply shock set up
where
the inventory on spot exchanges are
slowly depleting and that means that
less and less coins able to be bought
that puts a bullish
price pressure on and in this latest
pullback where we pull back from the 50
60 000 range into the 30s
you could also see a massive flow back
into
the exchanges so a lot of supply
being put back onto the market
so that's reverse supply shock but what
we're seeing
very recently over this kind of sideways
band is
actually those coins moving off again so
we're back in the sort of
supply shock trend upwards
and the other view of it is uh
actually it's the indicator you created
well it's um
it's a ratio of um like glass nodes
um measure like i was mentioning
of liquid supply essentially i call it
rick astley you know you've got two
types of
people in the market there's um the the
speculative guys that um
you can look on their wallets and you
can look at their history and see that
a lot of coins move in and out of their
wallets they
they are in the game to trade um more
than
most and then the other side is the the
investor that um
stacks their coins and not a lot leaves
from those wallets and i call those guys
the rick astley
recastes of this world they're not going
to really let go of their coins
um so when you draw a ratio between the
two is which what you did actually
you can create um the similar thing but
it's based on the quality
like as more coins flow into the strong
hands the rick astley's
versus the speculative hands you'll see
the same sort of
um supply shock you know the speculative
hands that
are willing to sell their coins whereas
the rick asks these aren't
they're holding and they're not going to
let the coins go um
so as the strong hands
gain more and more of those coins there
becomes a supply shock and the coins
held by
speculative hands is reducing so um i
look at that you know
and in both cases whether it's the
inventory on spot exchanges or
the qualitative view of um coins held by
the strong hands uh
they are really moving towards um
long-term holders
moving off exchanges and we're you know
if you look at the qualitative view
we're really making near
highs again we're back in the zones
where bitcoin was trading 55 60 000
and that's continuing to climb so it's a
very interesting time in the market
right now where the price
is divergent from on chain
the price action and technical view of
traders are selling down
there's a lot of shorts in the market
and it looks very kind of like a bearish
grind
meanwhile the on-chain picture shows a
lot of accumulation like very
ridiculously strong accumulation
that is not reflected in the
price action and we last saw this
in the months before kind of the october
where um price had been ranging sideways
it pumped up to
like what was it eleven thousand twelve
thousand people got really bullish and
then it dumped
um down to 10 000 and so the the
trajectory was downwards and sideways
and
all through that time um the supply
shock was
was um steeply rising steeply rising a
lot of coins moving off
exchanges a lot of rick astley
controlling more and more of the coins
um and that eventually um exploded into
a complete bullish run from november
onwards
um and if you if i recall um
you know the the narrative back then was
we just had this covered crash
back in you know the april uh may
april zone and um bitcoin was very very
correlated to
stocks so um and and gold was starting
to take off and people were saying
bitcoins are failed safe pavement it's
highly correlated to the stocks it
didn't
hold over this um this sort of
bearish crash we had um but the actual
unchain picture was completely different
it was at that point long-term investors
were stacking they were stacking hard
um supply shots started climbing
straight up
from that point um and actually it took
a number of months before the market
kind of priced that in and there was a
realization that the coins were running
dry
and you know it took a while for the
kind of speculative
volumes and in the in the market
to kind of get squeezed you know i kind
of picture
uh this the futures and derivatives
exchanges
having a huge dominance over the
short-term price and at that point
um the price was swinging wildly um
above
what i would have considered a you know
there's a particular floor that
investors will support and it was
trading above that but that floor
started climbing higher and higher
and at around that october price
kind of met that that floor
um estimate what long-term investors
were supporting and it bounced you know
and that was when the
the market um realized that there was
supply shock and we ran up to
um 40 then 50 and 60 000
so right now the structure's similar um
there's a lot of bearish people in the
market the price action reflects
bearishness and
underlying it there's like this
invisible um
you know accumulation from um long-term
investors
that i haven't seen anything like this
since october
last year it's interesting like
i think the key point there is kind of
the fact that there's this huge
divergence and
like i've been looking at some of these
charts lately and i've been like am i
crazy like because you know
this has been going on for so long now
and price keeps diverging from
from the fundamentals um but it is kind
of wild like you said
um looking at that other times i mean at
least in the last year or two
there hasn't been a a divergence this
large
since since you know like you mentioned
september so just waiting for that that
information to kind of get
priced in um but and you know in the
meantime it's like this thing is just
growing and growing and growing and
looking at that big uptick uh
you know in that liquid supply ratio
this week was pretty wild and then also
seeing um and i guess you could touch on
this if you want
um you know the uptick in whales where
that that's something i had been
watching for a while
um it was was the number of new whales
which have been trending down
but you had actually pointed out to me
that yeah the number of whales were
trending down but their supply
that they were holding was actually
moving up um since that big capitulation
event
so it's almost like you know supply was
getting concentrated into
older whales but then this week when we
had that big
uptick i think it was like 65 000 coins
uh
accumulated by by whale entities in in
one day
at the same time you had an uptick in
new whales so i think
that was interesting to see maybe you
know finally getting some some new large
buyers where
it had seemed like it was kind of um for
the most part kind of like older whales
by
yeah like the whole run down um
like a lot of the coins that were moved
um
between wallets um between entity
wallets different different participants
um they were very young coins you know
they came in um
you know like in the three to six months
band where they bought in
below 30 000 even 10 000 i think they
were very
much you know this was also the time
that wales was selling down and i think
that
that was reflective of um this kind of
new
thing we have in 2021 where you've got a
lot of
hedged funds now in the game and high
net worth
individuals and we know these guys came
in
around the start of this year and
um i mean it's interesting because
usually in a bull run
it's usually the the new guys that come
in they get shaken out
but they're usually the um you know what
would you say
like the new hands the noobs the noobs
get shaken out
and the the strong hands and the the old
guys they know exactly what's happening
in bull run they snap up those
those derps um this time we've had like
um
you know huge funds which are you know
supposedly savvy i mean to be savvy um
so it's heavy in
traditional finance um maybe they're not
so
uh savvy in um bitcoin um
they um took their profits they took a
lot of their profits off the table
um and so you ended up having whales
these huge whales dumping
dumping in a bull run onto effectively
much smaller
guys medium-sized people and retail who
are
you know they're stacking how they're
buying up these coins um so the dynamics
kind of flipped it's a very weird
cyclist one
um and it's interesting to see that blip
now um
yeah the the the it's more so the the
coins under control and i kind of wonder
if
you know what's your take on i'm i'm
wondering if there's yet
unannounced news you know maybe you know
like we know el salvador
was you know in for what 150 million in
the trust fund and they've
got about 135 million that they're going
to give out to their citizens
that's a fair amount of buying pressure
in the sideways band
but i kind of wonder if there's others
you know these like
eight latin american countries now very
kind of
bullish on bitcoin being a big thing for
their economy
um at least the making noises of it i i
do wonder if we've got
some unannounced news that we can see on
chain but
um you know we don't know what exactly
that is right now
willie one of the things that's really
interesting to me about all of this
is um as we see folks come into the
market i think most people
who pay attention to this stuff have
wrapped their heads around okay strong
hands are buying
and people who have been around for a
long time kind of understand cycles they
look for points
to accumulate but one of the things that
has changed
uh let's say maybe the last 12 months or
so we now have corporations
financial institutions and even nation
states
that are starting to actually buy
bitcoin
and hold it do you have any insight or
any way to kind of think through it from
a framework standpoint as to
maybe the quality of these long-term
holders or or a difference between let's
say
an individual who's been a long-term
holder been around for a while versus an
institution
a nation-state a corporation etc
um well like
definitely the quality completely
changes you kind of tend to have
much less signal coming from these kind
of guys because
the they they're very measured moves
like if you look at michael saylor's
micro strategy they're buying um kind of
in bulk
in um separate rounds he's actually you
know announcing it
before i guess for regulatory reasons so
it kind of gets front run a bit but
once those coins get mopped up um that's
just a whole bunch of supply locked away
um and you know there's not a lot of
signal coming from his wallet right it's
just
those coins are aging um and so
it's you know like in the old days of
like 2016 and the cycles before that
you know the on-chain had a lot of the
dominance and um it was just a sea of
participants and you could see all the
transactions
on chain and you kind of get this
um you know it's it's a lot more
um productive when you've got you know a
million people
individually acting rather than like
five
all right and and so i think that's
that's a lot of signal being removed
um and i i don't think on-chain
necessarily is useful for that i think
it's much more useful
actually picking up the phone and
talking to these guys
and the in the industry because uh you
know although these coins are held by
um a lot of um like
you know shareholders i guess split
owners within you know a corporation or
even a nation state there's a lot of
listed interests in those coins the the
decision power is very very centralized
so
um in that regard it starts to look a
little bit like a small altcoin
the um their holdings it's like these
people have very concentrated power to
just
move um their coins and it has a huge
impact you know even
like things like the grayscale um
bitcoin trust that's that's really
that's you know
holds three and a half percent of the
coins um and
you can see the impact of even the small
um you know way well it's to say the way
it's structured
um with the lock-ups and and
the design of that that instrument um
it has an impact on the market and a
significant impact and so
um yeah like these entities that
are very concentrated um obviously they
they they kind of add a shock to the
market if they do anything
so um you know i i don't know if it's an
on-chain thing we look at um
it's it's likely you know other data in
these conversations
willie one thing you'd kind of touched
on i just wanted to uh you know like
circle back to
i think a lot of the capital that you
know people kind of need to keep this in
mind a lot of the capital that
flew in or was flown into
the market you know towards call it you
know late last year
you know uh november december was
through grayscale for you know people
trying to do the arbitrage trade and
then also
you know the cash and carry trade the
you know the difference between the the
spot and future
long spots short in the future and just
kind of capturing that that basis
um you know i think a lot of and i think
you pointed this i don't remember
exactly who pointed this out but part of
that down
draw in wales kind of coincided with um
the spread between the futures and spot
dropping off so
i i suspect a lot of those whale
entities that we saw come in
um you know kind of at the beginning of
the bull run because i remember that was
a big narrative like
uh oh you know there's this huge uptick
in wales you know
it was like went vertical after we broke
all-time highs
um you know i suspect a lot of those
whales
weren't actually in bitcoin for the
asset itself and we're just kind of
seeing this
market neutral trade that they could
just you know take but they had to
they had to own the underlying
yeah i'm not i'm not sure how much of
the impact was from the market neutral
participants
to be honest because like we saw the
whales started to sell down
we saw the whale stud sell down quite
early i think it was
around march they started to sell down
[Music]
yet like the yields that you were
getting in the cash and carry trade was
climbing and claiming
it was it was getting very very
lucrative um
the yields only dropped off after we
kind of got down to the 40 and 30 000
mark and people and
people were interested in shorting and
mark it went into backwardation
um the you know at that point you
it made sense unwind out of your
position
right and because you're not doing yield
by holding your bitcoin and shorting it
anymore it's actually costing you money
and so
we did see um a little whale um holdings
drop
at that point and i think that was
responsible for that cash incur
carry um i i
kind of do think that this was a speaker
of wales you know like we
we know that rougher bought around 10
000 and they
sold a bit i mean the what was it the
was it in the
30s something like that and then they
sold the remainder in the 50s
yeah like um they they well they sold no
they sold this rails they sold some in
the elon musk pump but then they sold
the remainder
um and saying that oh
i think they cited that the kids weren't
going to be
um playing speculative games anymore
because covert was um coming to an end
or something like that
um and then i know the new zealand um
one of the retirement funds in new
zealand um kiwisaver
uh they they also bought in the 10 000
and they exited um in the 50 to 60
000 mark so the there's a couple of
known funds that i
i i know of um more that's well public
space
and um so we do know that there were
funds behaving in this way and if that's
the tip of the iceberg
there's certainly a lot more whales than
that than funds being announced that
they've bought bitcoins
so um there's probably a lot of this
action
happening um you know the fund managers
are highly connected
um they might be copy trading more or
less um
so yeah i i
i think we did get a bit of south side
and you you see that reflected in the
gbtc
inventory i'm not climbing anymore um
willie one of the things that uh always
fascinates me about the on-chain metrics
is
uh kind of this idea like that on-chain
metrics can't lie right the data is the
data how you interpret it could be
different for different people
um but but it's this real-time
transparent view into
what's happening in a part of the market
how do you think about
the on-chain metrics being kind of uh
more reactive or more of like a lagging
indicator for things so sentiment
changes than the on-chain metrics change
versus the on-chain metrics are really
driving maybe sentiment or other types
of
um activities in the market because it
feels like there's a relationship
where um you know if you kind of zoom
out and look historically
you can definitely tell okay at some
point in the market uh we saw a bunch of
the metrics change
and around the same time sentiment might
have changed but what do you
think about the relationship between
those two things
yeah it's a good question i mean there's
so many different metrics you can look
at
and i find some more productive than
others another certainly lagging
um and so um
you know it's it's it's that constant
search of finding the leading indicators
um and um yeah i
i think uh you know on chains really
it's you know these there's there's
short
medium and long-term on chain indicators
and some of the highest value you can
get
as an investor is the longer term staff
because you want to know
when is a good time to enter and when
you know it's probably highly risked in
worth taking some
money off the table um and so the macro
long-term indicators of unchained is
very
useful and whether or not you call that
predictive you might just say look
things are getting dicey here because
they're models are saying that
this is where the fundamentals are and
this is where the price is and when you
do the ratio between the two things are
very
highly um speculative in a you know
almost mania phase and and that kind of
stuff is
interesting it doesn't say the ma the
price is going to crash you can go even
higher but
it can tell you your risk um your
carrying is high
and it might be worth de-risking a bit
and um so that's that's kind of the
more macro so that's super useful um and
then you can
get into the shorter time frames like um
demand and supply that's happening over
the week to week
and um that stuff it's still pretty
reliable but it's
um you know it's not going to be
um it's not going to be perfect because
it's based on
interpretation it's it's based on
well these are markets anything can
happen like at one point
i remember i'm saying this thing is
tentatively recovering
i think i'm bullish and then but the key
thing was attentively recovering and
then elon musk's
tweets about tesla not accepting bitcoin
and validating
um this this fud on bitcoin
you know to the mainstream who they
aren't very clued on bitcoin they're
just validating this whole
rhetoric that's destroying the planet
with um fossil fuels and
and that totally um started this whole
bearish run and there's no way you can
predict that right on chain doesn't
predict
these market moves that are outside
you know like that basically means the
on on chain
investors that were staying got
sideswiped by some random
market doesn't mean it was wrong
in saying that you know investors are
buying and they're bullish
it just means that we didn't pick this
unpredictable event
and having said that on the short term
when i say short term maybe in the three
weeks out
i mean i do a letter and there's about
22
forecasts out now and the back trace is
um
high 70s or 80 percent reliable
um so if you're a trader um and you're
trading um a technical signal
typically you're doing really well
you're in the 55-60
percent accurate in your analysis so
on-chain currently even the short-time
training stuff
can be productive if you're looking at
the right stuff
what's up guys before we continue with
this interview i want to quickly talk
about our sponsor
kraken kraken's one of the most
established and secure places to buy
cryptocurrencies on the internet
they've been at the forefront of the
bitcoin and blockchain revolution for
over
10 years their mission is to bring
crypto to the masses
so whether you're an og or this is your
first trade
kraken has all of the tools that you
need to achieve financial freedom
with more than 60 cryptocurrencies
available you can invest in
all of the most popular projects in the
industry including bitcoin
ethereum and many many more kraken also
provides in-depth articles
and guides on every single asset that
they list so you can get up to speed
quickly and make smarter investment
decisions
visit kraken.com bang bang to get
started today
again that's kraken.com bang bang
alright let's get back into this
interview i hope you're enjoying it
got it and before we let you go maybe
talk a little bit just about where we
are today from a market structure
standpoint kind of what are you
looking for moving forward so are there
specific uh milestones
are there specific things happening with
yanchain data that you'll say you know
hey this is going to be a big moment
uh we don't know when it will happen but
i'm looking for it um or is it more so
you just wait till the on-chain metrics
develop and then
analyze what uh what kind of happens uh
in real time
yeah right now the big story is like
when does this um
accumulation band um pop like
i mean that's it sounds almost sunny
funny
you know if you talk to people on crypto
twitter um because everyone's so bearish
saying we're in a beer market and i'm
like
this is a bull market there's no
mistaking this like we've got x-ray
vision
on what the investors are doing and it's
bullish
whilst price is sliding downwards i
think the next major event is
when the fundamentals squeeze the price
action
and we we break out of this what i'd
call a re-accumulation ban
right in the middle of a bull market
like a
like a a beer shock that is now being
shrugged off um so that's the that's the
next thing i'm looking for
um and then um typically
once you know we usually get a few
pullbacks within a bull run
this is a really weird one um a whale
um powered pull back um but um
really after that i'm really interested
in seeing how
the tail end of this bull market
develops because um this bull market
is um you know it's structured unlike
any i've seen before
um and the the the market of
you know the whole market is completely
um different you know we've got very
well developed futures
and derivatives and options um and now
we've got you know
large etf instruments so and we've got a
lot of leveraging system you know block
fi
these kind of loans um and a lot of
hidden
leverage like that so it's getting a
more com
to become a more complex beast and i
think
we've already seen the way the price is
moving
um in this this you know this
epoch this happening epoc four year
cycle
it's unlike anything it's not smooth
it's lopsided
volatility all over the place and um i
really i'm just really interested in
seeing how they extract that structures
later on um i'm not predicting um
i'm not predicting you know waiting for
some event
in the end of the year i'm more like
using on-chain as a map to try and get a
grasp of what exactly is happening in
the market
and i have no idea what's going to
happen in fourth quarter
you know we've got like a nation state
coming on board
well that looked like on chain um you
know i've got lightning network with
that nation state
i'm starting to fire up and so there
will be a lot of activity locking into
that and taking it off the chain
um and trying to see if we can get some
data on that
um so yeah it's it's kind of a wait and
see and like
figuring it out as it comes willy do you
know any positive news is hoping come on
now
any positive news i think we just just
sort of talked about it um
i think the positive right right now
what's that i was gonna say
we're like we're the glass node opium
guys yeah yeah exactly
glass node hoping guys i think the
positive news is that
there is so much bearish trolling on
twitter you know um
you know like if we can get more and
more people bearish then um that'll be
certainly the bottom i want to ask you
what what's the
uh top model look like i know this is
you know kind of a reactive model that
um you know you can kind of gauge where
the trajectory of it is going right but
um i'm assuming that that's
your opinion on that has changed i know
you had been kind of looking at
you know two 300k i was just curious um
you know where that kind of stands in
your mind
oh yeah so um people like like to cite
that i have an opinion like i make a
prediction
all i'm doing is reading off the model
and like i get the luxury of saying the
ma the target is a moving target because
the model keeps changing because it's
basically
you know a moving average over the um
the market cap
is what it's based on and um
and it's at every top in the history of
bitcoin you know 12 year history
they're not saying it'll do it this time
because it's such a weird cycle but
that top model and there's another model
which frames the bottom
um they they give me an idea of where
the top may be
um and you know first quarter this year
we were arranging
up to the 300 to 400 000 range
right now um the top model was 157
000 today um of course it moves um
and so really it's looking
i don't know if we if we squeeze out of
this um accumulation band like i'm
expecting
i would say they will start curving
upwards and when the 250 to 350
000 range sounds a bit ludicrous right
now but that's what the model says
um if we hit it you know if we hit it
don't know if it will
would you be looking for um well i guess
a few things
so like obviously we're talking about
this reaccumulation when that when
that's kind of supply shock takes place
um do you suspect that you know shorts
because when you look at like funding
funding's been
negative for well over a month now um i
mean there's been a couple days of
slight positive but in general um do you
think there's a possibility of
us kind of getting this this short
squeeze on the way back up and then
second of all
um you know we we've been kind of
talking about funds that
got in in like you know 10 to 20k and
then had moved to take
took in profits um you know kind of at
the beginning of the year
do you think there's a lot of um there's
a lot of momentum
uh funds like kind of that that will
come in
if we have a breakout and kind of try to
ride that momentum wave right like so
maybe we'll see an uptick in wales or
whatever it may be
that's kind of showing like once we
break i don't know whatever it is
the 200-day moving average something
that kind of gives capital that's
sitting on the sidelines
um the confirmation that okay yeah maybe
we are waiting for lower prices but this
thing's now broken out to the upside
so now you know we feel confident to go
ahead and take a position do you think
you
you get that effect or like have you
gotten that effect in the past once
bitcoin breaks out of some major
resistance
yeah i um you know i will remember in
the 3000 four thousand bay and it broke
out and it was really was a squeeze i
can't remember
the the derivative um set up at that
point but looking at the
the squeeze it looked like um it was
primed
to pump upwards if it broke resistance
um presently there's
very very little interest um
compared to you know open interest is
very low the number of contracts in the
system is low
so i i'm not entirely sure if we'll get
a squeeze but
you know historically we we do squeeze
so squeezing meaning we get a very
violent
move and this time it'll be a short
squeeze because you're on shorting
so it'll move to the upside um
so i kind of expect it but right now i'm
not seeing enough
open interest to see anything really
very violent um but
i do think you're right and that as
as this thing starts to pick up momentum
and it shakes off all
this crazy bearishness of you know not
only do we have all this
crappy energy fossil fuel narrative
thrown at bitcoin and then we had
on top of that china shutting down all
of their uh mining
um which will take apparently roughly
six months for
all those miners to really move that
infrastructure and set it up and
redeploy it um
so the hash rate of the networks you
know i think what is it 40
down or something ridiculous so there's
a lot of bearishness that's been thrown
on
the queen it's still chugging along it
you know price pulled back um
50 but they're still doing well um
so if we shake that out and then we've
got
you know you look at the the the picture
we're seeing where
we've got um you know sovereign wealth
funds haven't really been much of a
story but
um and i'm quite interested in these
non-speculative huddlers
at very large scales like sovereign
wealth um
like el salvador loading up 150 million
for their trust i think singapore loaded
up on some bitcoin
but there's a number of um sovereign
wealth funds that i think
must be looking at at i'm accumulating
yet
you know i don't think we've seen much
of that yet and
um i think that's a story
for like the fourth quarter of this year
maybe um
if it happens and if it happens then
that's going to really change the cycle
because we have that kind of buying
power on on typically
what we'd expect to be near the end of a
bull market
we could see a a really different cycle
i kind of wonder if the cycle
um i'm calling it different like um dan
howard's calling this a super cycle i'm
thinking this might be the last
cycle meaning um at this point
bitcoin doesn't see this very strongly
imprinted four year cycle
and we we we do more of a random walk
and it's highly correlated to macro
and we just random walk all the way up
to a million dollars
in a few years really do you think
that's the top
why a million dollars why not uh 10
million
or 500 million plus you know i have
what is it there's there's no top to
bitcoin because fiat has no
no bottom was it um yeah i think that
we're
you know the the monetary base
of civilization is about to be um reset
um more than reset reinvented um i'm
looking at this it's like people are
looking at this as reset of the
long-term debt cycle you know
um reinventing money money gets
reinvented every roughly 100 years and
i'm like going
well if you look at when money was
invented there was the agrarian age you
know so we had we shifted from
not not trading to actually using money
in
agriculture and all this technological
um advancements and that led to
civilization
and i think this is the same thing we're
going from
this kind of industrial age to a digital
age um
but you know it's a real first
reinvention of money since the agrarian
revolution it's a one
in ten thousand year event um it's not a
100 year
reset so um yeah
it's it's i think it's gonna it's gonna
um
the top on it is um roughly one to one
to world gdp
in market cap which is what a hundred
trillion
[Music]
uh i think i concur with um plan b
plan b is 100 trillion uh so
um there might be a quadrillion by the
time more money gets printed
it's interesting what you had kind of
touched on about the cycles this is
something
i've kind of thought about like over
over time obviously the the supply shock
has less of an effect right like you
like you've analogized it's a bathtub
where you're sitting in a bathtub and
you have that push
and then that gives it the momentum and
then obviously like you know just
market behavior greed kind of kicks in
and you know drives the speculative
rally up throughout the bull run but you
know over time
that push um you know the pool of water
is getting bigger so it has
not as large of an effect right um on on
that
that kind of supply shock so over time
i almost like to think of it as like the
the having's got the initial kind of
inertia going
for the adoption right where it gave
people a monetary incentive to come in
and buy this thing because of the
you know just the pure monetary
appreciation of it but then
it gets to a point where the the havings
aren't necessarily driving
people in through that supply shock but
the demand kind of just takes over the
adoption and
the network effects of bitcoin once it
has that inertia going that momentum
going
um then you know that's it's kind of
just doesn't really
matter as much as the pure demand from
that aspect and then like you're
saying you know as bitcoin becomes
larger as it becomes a multi-trillion
dollar asset
it's going to be much more adapt to um
you know following kind of macro trends
and and what that landscape is looking
like
yeah i'm really i'm interested in the
last last cycles because it's really
um i don't put some metrics to it
because it's really based on what you're
saying the supply shock right
supply shock is what creates these four
year cycles and the cell pressure from
the last supply shop was 1800 bitcoins
per day down to 900. so
900 bitcoins are being mined every day
to and that's been sold off right that's
the sale pressure
um now we're in the cycle where there's
so much dirt of trading
um that you can picture um
you know 1 000 to 2 000 bitcoin
potentially
being harvested as fees by the exchanges
um and that's potential sale pressure if
they're selling to pay shareholders and
salaries
so um the the sale pressure from
exchanges
like mining um it's like a tax on trade
and then selling constant cell pressure
um that that's really the same size as
is the current um like mining you know
and then we're going to drop to 450
bitcoins per day at the next
harvening epoch at that point it's the
minuscule the
the least of the um the cell the cell
power
like to put this in perspective um from
you know grayscale's two percent
of their their coins under custody for
that
um that fund that um
pseudo etf fund generates a sale power
of 36 bitcoins per day
probably all the etfs combined
currently is just over 40 bitcoins per
day compared to miners
that are doing 900 so
um by the next happening etfs will be
10 percent of mining power is cell
pressure um and so i want to i want to
do this thing where you
add all the sale pressure the exchanges
the etfs and all these
kind of products that right on top of
bitcoin that extract fees
and bitcoin value and then they sell to
see it
i think the mining story is now going to
be a thing of the past
um it'll be there but it'll be less
important than these new market
influences we're seeing
i think also like miners are
you know the most bullish on the asset
of anybody in the space because you know
bitcoin were to go away like
all of their capex would just be deemed
worthless right like all their machines
would just be paperweights at that point
so you know when you look over time
miners actually have
a pretty strong tendency to hold their
coins um
and even recently you know people have
been talking about um
you know miners have played this huge
role in the selling pressure downward
but
at least you know in glasgow's data
you're only seeing you know like
a little over 5 000 coins that were sold
down you know kind of amidst that month
in there
um which in that now over the last two
weeks it looks like they've actually
started
slightly accumulating again so um yeah i
think i think kind of like the whole
narrative about minor selling has kind
of been overstated
yeah i mean it's like uh i mean there
was a dip that dip
was uh if it was 5 000 as you you quoted
um that was very shortly after the
mining the miner banned
in china and um presumably it made sense
for miners to
sell coins because some of them are
getting out of the game and liquidating
for real
and others um selling out to fund
relocation
um but after that sell-off um we're an
accumulation
of coins by the miners and they're not
selling and
it's it's very much what you see with
the bottom um the miners
the strong miners are left the strong
miners being the ones that didn't get
shut down by china
um and so they know it's a bottom
because the sail pressure
is um is gone now um
so yeah it's and and interestingly the
the mining
the mining um you know norm like it's
really weird to be looking at the mining
equation in the middle of a bull market
and i mean
typically the cell pressure from miners
is very
small compared to the full force of
buying of a of a fully
um unleashed bitcoin bull market and so
we're in this kind of tenses of band
we're going sideways where it kind of
does matter
but normally um you know back to the
first um conversation
there's like you know three or four
hundred metrics you can look at on chain
um and mining right now is is is being
pulled out of the toolkit um
whereas normally we don't look at that
much during a bull run um
very little signal because this our
pressure is very low
in a bull run but right now it's
important if you don't mind just touch
on um
you know the well multiple which kind of
dipped into a buy zone
briefly um and then as well the the
difficulty ribbons right
um it's something i don't think a lot of
people are familiar with
yeah i am not very familiar with the pro
multimeter i remember
he created it and we was like went over
the equation but it was like two years
ago and i haven't um
haven't i haven't got in my head right
now um it's the issuance divided by the
365 day
moving average of issuance in dollar
terms
so when you when you had right so like
when you had the the block slow down
um i think that coincided with why you
had such a steep drop in it because
minor revenue was less because there was
less
gotcha okay so that basically um pure
moldable
and the ribbon is very much moving the
same thing then
so what you're looking at is um you know
the bitcoin network
generates hash rate from the miners and
then that
um also translates into difficulty um
the the network makes it more difficult
for miners
to mine right and so the two things the
hand in hand
and the two things are matched to keep
the um the block time
every 10 minutes therefore the issuance
should be
roughly the same the pool multiples
measuring the localized
issuance and what we saw was the
issuance dropped off a cliff because
the hash rate dropped off the cliff and
the difficulty
takes two weeks to adjust and so
um so essentially the whole the whole
network started processing blocks even
up to three times slower than normal
um and so
estuan's was one-third during those
times
and um typically when you see that
common event happening
where issuance is so slow um
and you'll you'll see this drop and it
really is um very similar to
um what i'm measuring with difficulty
ribbon which is also measuring this drop
and difficulty which is a bit lagged
it lags hash rate you know the hash
rate's dropped and the inductivity will
correct
downwards and as it is correcting
downwards
um eventually this thing bottoms um and
new miners start adding hashtag into the
market
and um what we're really looking at is
what i call a minor's capitulation
the um the weak miners just got
liquidated
they could not typically in the beer
season as the price goes lower and low
and low eventually the weakest minus to
a
least efficient on optics and
electricity costs they get
they get um they get run into a loss and
then eventually they um
they exit they exit by selling off their
coins closing on operations to pay for
their losses and so those bitcoins get
dumped onto the market
those that sell pressure drops the price
a bit
and then that liquidates the next week
as miners and eventually you capitulate
all the miners down until the last
um biggest baddest miners that are very
efficient
um are left and so it's a weak minor
color
um and then um the strong miners know
it's the bottom because the weak guys
got shaken out and the sour pressure
subsided that whole
cell cascade of weak miners has
now ended and um the buying can begin
um so they know that they're not going
to sell anymore they're going to hold
their coins and
and so the different ribbon you'll
you'll see that if we drop
and we'll see a visual compression in
that ribbon and then you'll see it
recover
and there's a visual view of that that
capitulation again and the pure multiple
is very much similar um in measuring
that
instead looking at it as a side effect
of issuance
because it's effectively um those block
times and
and how difficulty and hashrate work
together
willie i feel like will and i could talk
to you forever uh unfortunately we can't
do that on a uh on a podcast or on
youtube
before we let you go explain to everyone
uh the email that you put together and
kind of the analysis and research that
you do with the onshane metrics and
where they can go find more if they're
interested
yeah sure i launched this october last
year it was kind of a good time because
it was like the start of this bull run
and the idea is really to give
investors particularly investors that
are relatively new to the market
like a market intelligence newsletter to
see um what's actually happening with
investors as we're seeing it on chain
so they can make informed decisions um
because we see a lot of
investors come in they buy they get they
get freaked out by the volatility
and particularly bull market you get
these shakeouts so i put that letter out
i called it the i call it the bitcoin
forecast
it effectively takes all these metrics
that we get off
glass node i reprocess it i
add my commentary and predictions based
on that
and that's available on
sub stack currently so you can just go
to my twitter handle
it's woonnomic it would nomik and
there's a link there to my sub stack
and um that's available if you want to
subscribe um
awesome listen thank you so much for
taking that time to do this we'll make
sure that there's a link in the
description
uh to send people over there will any
last closing words
yeah um hang in there guys
this thing's gonna pop
will clemente anything from you uh i
just wanted to say
you know thanks for coming on willie
obviously you know uh
you know you're very instrumental in
kind of my understanding of all this
stuff it was
is actually a podcast he did with peter
i think it was like in in december or
something it was like right after we
broke out all-time highs
and like just listening to you kind of
you know explain how everything
was moving on chain is really
fascinating to me i think you know we
kind of get insight into
um activity and investor activity that
you don't get in any other market so
stuff really is fascinating and i
appreciate you you know taking the time
out to
you know communicate back and forth with
me and then also just come on and this
is awesome for me so thanks
yeah thanks will it's been really great
to see you come in there and sort of
take the torch it's like a new
generation on chain analysts coming in
and and helping build up the space so
it's really great to see
um good on you for that thanks buddy
awesome guys thank you guys so much and
we'll do it again in the future okay
catch you later